شكرا جمال مرحبا بكم في هذه النافذه
الجديده للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب
اسرائيل على قطاع غزه وفيها نستضيف المحلل
العسكري اللواء فايز الدويري اهلا بك لواء
دويري قبل ان نبدا في النقاش نتابع الان
اخر تطورات المشهد ميدانيا على الخريطه
التفاعليه مع الزميل عبد القادر عراض عبد
القادر تطورات لافته شهدتها اليوم نعم
وسيله ولعل ابرزها في الشمال وحينما نتحدث
عن الشمال نشير اذا ما قاله المتحدث
العسكري الاسرائيلي من انهم في الشمال
يعيشون نوعا ما حرب عصابات مع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بينما الاشتباكات
شرسه تواجه بها القوات الاسرائيليه من قبل
المقاومه في الجنوب وتحديدا في خان يونس
لكن لنذهب مباشره الى هذه التطورات
المتلاحقه والمتسارع في منطقه الشمال
وتحديدا في هذه المناطق في الشيخ رضوان
منذ قليل كان حديث لكتائب القسام عن
استهداف مركبات اسرائيليه اربع مركبات
اسرائيليه هنا في حي الشيخ رضوان كان هناك
ايضا الحديث عن استهداف تسع مركبات اخرى
في منطقه الدرج في في غزه اذا نحن نتحدث
عن استهدافات لعدد كبير من المركبات
الاسرائيليه في هذه المناطق التي شهدت على
مدار هذه الاسابيع المتل حقه وتقريبا 80
يوما منذ بدايه الحرب شهدت اشتباكات
ولازالت المقاومه تقول كلمتها في هذه
المواقع ربما النقطه الاخرى المرتبطه
بالتطورات هنا في جباليا جباليا هي محور
رئيسي للاشتباكات ولكن للاستهداف
الاسرائيلي القوات الاسرائيليه كما نعلم
حاولت تطويق
هذه جباليا ومخيم جباليا ومحاوله التوغل
نحو غرب جباليا لكنها لم تص صل الى قلب
المدينه لازالت الاشتباكات قائمه القسام
وايضا سرايا القدس تحدثت عن استهدفت في
هذه المواقع لقوى اسرائيليه راجله يا اما
بقذائف تنوم او قذائف ايضا الياسين لكن
ايضا كان هناك استهداف لمركبات اسرائيليه
في جباليه نذهب الى نوعا ما جنوبا وتحديدا
الى الشجاعيه في الشجاعيه التي ايضا شهدت
توغلا للقوات الاسرائيل
ايضا كان هناك استهداف لاليات اسرائيليه
ودبابات في منطقه الشجاعيه دبابه ميركافا
تحديدا قالت سرايا القدس انها استهدفتها
في منطقه الشجاعيه لكن اللافت ايضا ان جحر
ديك تعود الى واجهه الاحداث بل انها لم
تغادر الاحداث من خلال تطوراتها المتلاحقه
نحن حينما نشير الى جحر الديك نشير الى
المنطقه الجنوبيه من مدينه غزه في جحر
الديك كان هناك استهداف ايضا لمجموعه
متحصنه ظاهره استهداف المنازل التي يتحصن
فيها جنود اسرائيليون اصبحت متكرره هذا
الاستهداف كان من سرايا القسام في منطقه
جحر الديك وهو تطور لافت يضاف الى
استهدافات سابقه كانت لجنود اسرائيليين في
ذاته المنطقه لو ذهبنا الى المناطق
الجنوبيه نحن نتحد
نتحدث عن هذه التطورات في المنطقه
الجنوبيه ويبدو بان هناك بالفعل هناك جديد
هناك فيديو نعرضه عليكم الان لهذه الصور
التي حصلت عليها الجزيره لمعارك بين
المقاومه والجيش الاسرائيلي في غزه
نتابع
[موسيقى]
الله
s
[موسيقى]
ا
شباك
شباكه في
[موسيقى]
شريطه
وما رميت اذ رميت ولكن الله رمى يا رب مسن
يا الله الله
[موسيقى]
اكبر الله ا
تراون الحمد لله ضرب الغرفه احتراف كل ما
[موسيقى]
فيها
c
[موسيقى]
g
شباكين شباك من جنسين لثلاثه باذن الله
حنا على في شويه باذن
[موسيقى]
الله وما رميت اذ رميت ولكن الله رمى يا
رب مسن يا الله الله
اكبر
[موسيقى]
الحمدله ضرب الغرفه احتراف كل ما
فيها
[موسيقى]
الله
sch
[موسيقى]
جو
شباكين شباك
منسه باذن الله في شريطه باذن
[موسيقى]
الله
وما رميت اذ رميت ولكن الله رمى يا رب مسن
يا
الله الله
[موسيقى]
ا كما ترون الحمد لله ضرب الغرفه احتراف
كل ما
[موسيقى]
فيها
اذا هذه الصور التي نشرتها كتائب القسام
لمعارك تدور بين قوات المقاومه والجيش
الاسرائيلي في مدينه غزه استهداف للاليات
والجنود كذلك الاسرائيليين من المسافه صفر
كيف تعلق لواء دويري على هذه الصور في بعض
الحالات مجبر ان اعلق ولكن الصمت ابلغ من
الكلام هذا المقاتل يعلم الناس معنى
الرجوله والتضحيه والدفاع عن الارض والعرض
عندما يصل الى دبابه تعتبر الاحدث او من
الاحدث في العالم ويصل لها ويتحرك من
المقدمه الى مؤخره الدبابه لانها نقطه
الضعف في هذه المنطقه ويضع حشوه شوار هذا
كان احتمال
99% ان يستشهد ولكنه في سبيل اداء المهمه
والدفاع عن الشرف والكرامه والارض والعرض
فعل ما فعل واستطاع ان
ينجح في اللقطه الثانيه عمليه الاستهداف
في التي بي جي او
بالقاذف الياسين لتدمير الجرافه هذه اعمال
هي تمثل اعلى مستوى يمكن ان يحلم به
القائد ان يرتقي بجنوده الى هذا المستوى
من الاداء هذا المستوى من الاداء قد لا
تجديه في قوات دلتا ولا في الجرين اريتس
في الجيش الامريكي ولا في نخب مشاه
البحريه الامريكيه ولا في ولا في لواء
الجرذان البريطاني لكنه نجد عند فصائل
القسام وبقيه الفصائل وبالتالي هؤلاء
حقيقه يحصل على العلام الكامل هذا لو اردت
ان اقيم هذا الاداء واذا اجيز لي سامنحك
ليس هو فقط كل من ظهر في هذا الفيديو لانه
[__] يعني لاحظ اللحظه التعبيريه الفارقه
يتحرك من بين الاموات ليعيد بسمه الحياه
الى شفاه اهل غزه هذا هذا المعنى المجازي
لهذا الفيلم نعم هو وصل ودمر وقتل وان يصل
الى المسافه صفر للاليات الاسرائيليه
للجنود هؤلاء الجنود الذين توغلوا الى
المدينه مدينه غنز هم يعلمون ان هناك
المقاومه الفلسطينيه كيف سمحوا لهذه كيف
سمحوا لانه اصلا مصاب بالرعب وهو يحتمي
الان يحتمون داخل هو هو مسجون داخل هذا
الصندوق الحديدي لانه يعتقد انه امن ومحمي
وبالتالي الان اجهزه الدرع الواقي او
الستره المعطف الواقي والستره الواقيه هي
غير فعاله ضد هذه الاجراءات ان يتحرك يحمل
حشوه الشواظ وهي على شكل حرف في مغلفه
بالنحاس وبالتالي هي حتى الكلمه هذه هذه
من المكتسبات التي تم الحصول عليها
المكتسبات لكن عندما نتحدث عن الذي وضع
حشوه الشواظ اسفل الدبابه هذا امر خارق
للعاده تكر يجب على هذه اللقطات ستدرس
ستدرس في المعاهد العسكر تكررت مشاهد
الاستهداف للاليات والجنود الاسرائيلين عن
المسافه او من المسافه صفر هنا هل هناك اي
اختلاف هل هناك اي شيء مختلف عن المرات
السابقه الان هذه اللقطه شاهدنا لقطات
مماثله لها ولكن في حشوات لاصقه ليست حشوه
الشواف هذه حشوه كبيره تزن بعض في قسم
منها يصل الى 20 كيلوغرام من المتج ما
قدرتها تدميريه نعم قدرتها تدميريه انت
لاحظت النتيجه عندما تم اذا تعاد اللقطه
ستلاحظي الدبابه د رت في مكانها هذه حوالي
20 كغم من المتفجرات لانه كان يحملها بثقل
ويسير بها ولكن لحظي لحظه الانفجار ماذا
تعمل في الدبابه وبالتالي هي خارقه للدروع
هي مدمره للدبابه هي لقد لاحظنا الدبابات
التي تم سحبها كانت معطله لا هذه الشواط
سيكون التاثير اكبر من اللي شاهدناها في
اللام الفيديوهات التي عرضتها القسام
والذي تم سحب احد الدبابات بثلاثه ج رفات
اذا هذه اللقطات الاخرى لا تقل روعه ولا
مهاره عندما عندما يستهدف الشباك ويوجد به
قناصين وجدي اصلا من اجل تنفيذ عمليه
القنص وه عمليه القنص فيما يبدو انها
باستخدام بندقيه الغول لا عمليه القصف
التي لاحظناها في الشباك كانت في تي بي جي
كانت في تي بي جي لانه لاحظ الانفجار ولاه
القاذف امامنا ه هذه ل الجارفه هذه
الجارفه ستعاد اللقطه
الاخرى يعني احتمال ان نشاهد اللقطه
الاخرى لاحظي ه هذه هي التي بي جي هذه
التي بي جي مسافتها 130 متر الحد الاقصى
الفاعل لها وهو الان هذه الشبابيك يوجد
فيها قناصين في كل شباك اثنين الى ثلاث في
الفيديو قنص جنود جندي اثنين الى ثلاث
وبالتالي تم هذا قناص ينتظر ان يقتل مدني
امراه رجل طفل لا فرق لا اخلاق لا قيم لكن
بالمقابل هناك انسان يتمتع بالقيم
والاخلاق والمبادئ يدافع عن ارضه وعرضه هو
استهدف القناص ولم يستهدف امراه لاحظنا
الفيديو الذي نشر عن العسير عن الام
وابنتها الاسيرات ماذا تحدثوا عن رجال
المقاومه هذه اللقطات وعاده ما يتم
استهداف القناصين اما بالمدافع او ا الان
حسب
حسبب المكان الموجود في القناص الاسرائيلي
ويعتمد على المسافه كذلك محسب المكان
الموجود وما هي طبيعه المكان الان اذا
اتيح له ان يستخدم تي بي جي فالتي بي جي
هنا في حاله الاصابه المحققه هي قد تقتل
كل من في المبنى لانه تسبب حريق وانفجار
بينما في حاله البندقيه الغول طلقه واحده
لشخص واحد وبالتالي عند اصابه الشخص الاول
قد يحاول الاختباء الشخص الثاني واللافت
كذلك لواء دويري انه منذ بدء الاجتياح
البري في غزه تكررت كذلك مشاهد استهداف
الجنود الاسرائيليين داخل المنازل التي
يحتمون فيها هل يمكن القول ان كتائب
القسام ان المقاومه تستدرج هؤلاء وتنجح في
كل مره في استدراجهم الى كمائن ن ن المثال
الاوضح اي كم فوهه نفق تم تفجيرها حسب اذا
لم اخطئ ثمانيه مرات اعيدت نفس العمليه
نفس المقاربه تفخيخ النفق او فتحه النفق
ثمانيه فيديوهات شاهدناها وبالتالي كان في
كل مره يخطئ ويتم اقتناصه كذلك في عمليات
الوجود قبل قبل حوالي ساعه من الان تم
قرانا خبر عاجل انه تم استهداف منزل به 40
جندي في جباليا نعم في جباليا ما بين
وتوزعوا ما بين قتيل وجريح اما الا دا لا
استطيع ان وربما في الساعه الاخيره كانت
هناك العديد من الاخبار العاجله عن
استهدافات عديده ق هذه اللحظه هذه اللحظه
فارقه هذه اللحظه فارقه لماذا قوات جيش
الاحتلال بدات بالانسحاب وبدات بالانسحاب
تحت الاشتباك لم تنسحب كما في الهدنه في
الهدنه اعاده انتشارها اعاده تموضع اعاده
تموضع واعاده انتشار بدون رمايه وبدون ان
يكون في حاله اشتباك ما يجري الان هو
ينسحب تحت الضغط ينسحب في لحظه الاشتباك
في لحظه الانسحاب في هذه
الحاله القوات المنسحبه وحتى وان كانت
اقوى تكون في موقف ضعيف لانها تحاول ان
تتخلص من من معركه فاشله هنا بالمقابل حتى
لو كان الجانب الاخر اقل امكانات وقدره
لكن العامل النفسي والمعنوي لديه يرتفع
بصوره كالبوم تر لماذا لان ه هذا العدو
الذي هو اقوى منه بالامكانات هو ينسحب
امامه فتكون الروح المعنويه عاليه ويتم
ايقاع الخسائر وغد ان غدا لناظره قريب
لنرى ماذا سيعلن الاقت وهذا ما حدث لواء
دويري قبل ثلاثه ايام عندما انسحبت
الكتيبه الث ع نعم ما تاثير هذا الانسحاب
على سير العم هي كانت لحظه فارقه في معارك
القاطع الشمالي اللحظه الفارقه الحقيقيه
في القاطع الشمالي يوم اعلن قبل ثلاثه
ايام عن سحب كتيبه الكتيبه 13 من لواء
جولاني وقلنا من ذلك اليوم ان المؤشرات
العامه ستغير اتجاه البوصله لان هذا الجيش
تيقن قادته على المستوى التكتيكي
والعملياتي انه غير قادر على انجاز المهمه
افرت في استخدام النيران كشفت الفيديوهات
حجم الجرائم التي مارسها هذا الجيش اللا
اخلاقي ولكن كان لزاما عليه ان ينسحب لانه
لو بقي كانت المعركه في تصعيد والخسائر
اكبر وهو لا يتحمل هذه الفاتوره وبالتالي
هو انكف الخارطه الان لو تعرض الخارطه
الحديثه والمناطق الملونه باللون الاصفر
سيفاج المشاهد ان نصف هذه المنطقه قد اعيد
الى اللون الطبيعي ولن تبقى الا بعض
المناطق المحدوده في داخ في جباليه ومخيم
جباليا والشيخ رضوان والمناطق الزراعيه
ولكنه سيخرج منها عاجلا ام اجلا هذه
الاستهدافات المتكرره والخسائر التي
يتكبدها الجيش الاسرائيلي بالامس كانت
الخسائر كبيره جدا كيف تؤثر على نفسيه
الجندي الاسرائيلي الان في هذا اليوم تم
عزل احد قات السرايا في في احد الكتيبه 51
قبل عده اسابيع تم طرد وانهاء خدمات قائد
سريه ومساعد قائد سريه اي لاحظنا يوم
انسحاب الكتيبه 13 وكان كان هناك احتفالا
غنائيا للجنود
وقالوا قالوا بان هذا الاحتفال هو نوع من
ال التسلي والترفيه وانا علقت في ذلك وقلت
لا هذه رقصه الحبشي الذبيح للشاعر ابراهيم
طوقان بان فرحه ورقصه كان لانه نجى من
المهلكه نجى من من المحرقه وبالتالي كان
هو يرقص فرحا لانه خ خلص من من موقف مازوم
و بالتالي بدات البوصله تتغير في الشمال
وعلينا ان ننتظر اسبوعين الى اسبوعين ونصف
ستغير اتجاه البوصله في الجنوب كما اتوقع
طبعا في هذه الاثناء او هذا المساء هناك
اجتماع لمجلس الحرب نتنياهو كان قد تحدث
في الكنيست عن ضروره زياده الضغط العسكري
لاسترجاع المحتجزين برايك في ضوء هذه
المعطيات الجديده على الارض كيف سيكون
مسار اعتقد ان هذه الافلام هي كوابيس
ليليه لنتنياهو ولوزير الدفاع ولرئيس
الاركان وقد يبداوا يحلموا بجحر الديك
وبشجاعة
ينقذ رهينه واحده ولكنه انقذ اكثر من 100
من خلال طاوله التفاوض وبالتالي حتى الان
اعتقد ان طاوله التفاوض ليست جاهزه لان
المعطيات الميدانيه تقول ان يد القسام هي
العليا وبالتالي عليه ان يرضخ لشروط
القسام لا ان يفرض شروطا على القسام والان
هو يتحدث عن مرحله ثالثه من هذه الحرب لكن
ان يرى فيديو كهذا دلاله ذلك برايك و كيف
يفهم ذلك ان يخرج هذا الفيديو من مدينه
غزه يعني انا اتساءل ما هي المرحله
الثالثه وساجي المرحله الثالثه لاي محلل
استراتيجي اي يعتد بعلمه وبقدرته يجد انها
مرحله انكفاء ومرحله اعلان هزيمه واقرار
بالهزيمه هو تحدث بانه سينسحب ويخلق نطاقا
عازلا او منطقه عازله ويقوم بعمليات نوعيه
مستقبليه كلما تقتضي الحاجه لماذا هو ذهب
بهذا الاتجاه لجمله اسباب عدم القدره على
تحقيق الاهداف في الحد د الادنى الانشقاق
داخل مجلس الحرب و وما بين الاعضاء
العسكريين ورئيس الوزراء الوضع الاقتصادي
المتدهور خاصه بعد تدخل انصار الله
الحوثيين
واغلاق مضيق باب المندب وال التراجع
المواقف
وتراجع شعبيه الرئيس بايدن الى الى 34%
هناك مجموعه من المعطيات ان تجمعت جميعها
وتحركت في اتجاه واحد واج اجبرته على على
التحول الى المرحله الثالثه اذا هو تحول
اضطراري نحو الاسوا ولكنه لا يزال يفرض في
استخدام القوه حاول تنشيط ودفع الوي في
المطقه خان يونس لعله يحقق ما عجز عن
تحقيقه في الشمال ولكن اقول ان منطقه بن
سهيلا وما حولها
ستكون ستكون المنطقه الشماليه نزها وعن
هذا الافراط في القوه اسرائيل استخدمت قوه
تدميريه هائله في هذه الحرب ونحن في
هذا الاستخدام المفرط للقوه هل هو دليل
قوه ام هو مؤشر تخبط
وضعف هو دليل
اجرام لا تخبط ولا ضعف ولا قوه هو دليل
اجرام ما حصل في السابع من اكتوبر حطم
اسطوره الجيش الذي لا يقه واهدر كرامه ذلك
الجيش واهدر كرامه القياده السياسيه
وبالتالي ما يجري هو نوع من الحقد وحب
الانتقام وحب التدبير عندما يهاجم مدارس
الاونر ويكون فيها اطفال ونساء هل هذه
معايير اخلاقيه حد الحروب لها اخلاق هل
هذه معايير هو عندما فشل في مواجهه الرجال
المقاومه بدا ينتقم النساء وقديما يعني
اسد علي وفي الحروب نعامه جفنا تجف من
الصفير الطائر وطبعا نعود لمشاهده هذه
الصور والتعليق عليها ربما اللافت انها
تاتي مثل ما قلنا بعد 80 يوم من القصف
الجوي المتواصل ومن داخل مدينه غزه
المحاصره والتي توغل فيها الجيش
الاسرائيلي واستخدم فيها اسلحه وقنابل
ثقيله 80,000 طن حتى هذا اليوم بمعدل 1000
طن وهناك المزيد سيصل من قبل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه من المعدل العام لوزن
القنابل التي تلقى على قطاع غزه 1000 طن
يوميا
800000 طن ما القي على هورشيما ونجازاكي
35000 طن باستثناء التاثير الذري اذا
مرتين ونص ما القي على غزه ضعف مرتين ونص
ما القي على هورشيما
ونجازاكي ما القي على غزه والتدمير
الممنهج في غزه ال المدن الالمانيه
واليابانيه لم تشهده خلال اربع سنوات من
الحرب العالميه الثانيه ورغم نتحدث عن
ورغم ذلك الاهداف العسكريه لم
تتحقق طيب المرحله الثالثه ما الذي يمكن
ان تحققه اسرائيل في المرحله الثالثه ولم
تحقق في المرا المرحله الثالثه ما هي
المقاربه التي بنيت عليها الانسحاب من
المناطق المبنيه الى المناطق الزراعيه
وتعادل تقريبا 150 ك مربع حوالي نصف مساحه
قطاع غزه الان
تاريخيا غزه كانت
محتله وفي عام
2006 شارون بكل جبروته وطغيانه واجرامه
اصدر امر الانسحاب لانهم لم يعد يحتمل حجم
الخسائر اذا الاحتلال بمعنى الاحتلال الى
زوال لانه في في امر سابق كان هناك ثلاث
مرات تفرض فيها منطقه عاجله في المناطق
الزراعيه اخرها
تم كيف تم
التغلب عليها في مسيرات العوده ليس
المقاومه المقاومه كانت من وراء سرا
مظاهرات مسيره العوده خرج الشعب ابناء غزه
الشرفاء المدافعين خرجوا وكانوا يوصلوا
الى السيا في ايام محدده من الاسبوع
واستطاعت ان تجبر جيش الاحتلال على
الاعتراف بالواقع لا بل الامر ابعد من ذلك
اتمنى على القسام ان يطالب باعاده رس راسم
خط الهدنه وليس حدود غزه خط الهدنه قبل
اتفاقيه التعايش 1950 كانت مساحته 556 م
مربع كافه كافه مستوطنات الغلاف هذه على
ارض غزه حسب اتفاقيه عام الهدنه
1949 طيب اذا ما عدنا الى ميزان القوه
بالتاكيد اسرائيل متفوقه بالعتاد والاسلحه
وعدد جنود كذلك اذا ما تحدثنا عن الاسلحه
التي تستخدمها المقاومه ان كان في القنص
في استهداف الاليات والمدرعات الاسرائيليه
على ماذا تعول المقاومه الان من ناحيه
الاسلحه اولا قبل
الاسلحه قبل السلاح السلاح يجب ان يكون
بيد رجل مؤمن بقض مؤمن بقضيته لديه القدره
والمهاره وعنده الاستعداد للتضحيه اذا اذا
لو ننظر الى موازنه القوى لا يمكن لعاقل
ان يفكر
بان هناك مجال للانتصار او هناك مجال
للحركه ضد الاحتلال سترفع الرايه البيضاء
لكن عندما تكون الامور بنيت من اصل عقدي
بني على قدسيه وحرمه الارض والعرض والشرف
العربي العربي يتغنى بشرفه العربي تاريخيا
حتى في الجاهليه كان يتغنى بشرفه وبالتالي
مدلول الشرف عند العربي وفي الثقافه
العربيه اتمنى على الغرب ان ان يفهم هذا
مدلول لكن رغم الحصار من 2006 هناك حصار
من 2013 حصار مطبق رغم ذلك بداوا يستخدموا
كل ما اتيح لديهم من اجل
ووظفوا عندما تتحدث عن هؤلاء المقاتلين هل
يعلم البعض ان معظمهم يحمل درجه الماجستير
في الفيزياء في الكيمياء في الحاسوب هؤلاء
هؤلاء ليسوا اميين وجهله هؤلاء سخروا
العلم الذي لديه امكانيات بسيطه جدا سخروا
الامكانيات من خلال الهندسه العكسيه واكد
واعيد اكثر من واعدت اكثر من مره وظفوا
الهندسه العكسيه من اجل انتاج هذه هذه
المعدات التي تبدو في ظاهرها متواضعه وفي
جوهرها الحقت الذل والعار بجيش الا وفع
بشكل كبير اشكرك جزيل الشكر اللواء فايز
الدويري حدثنا هنا في الاستوديو ختام هذه
الفقره العسكريه الخاصه بحرب اسرائيل على
غزه نعود الان الى غرفه الاخبار والزملاء
هناك الى
اللقاء